gerade war ja noch der deutsche
fernsehpreis im großen studium coloneum
in köln jetzt wird abgebaut und wer
gefehlt hat ich habe die ganze zeit
angerückt war nina hagen dieses nicht im
publikum sonst ich glaube die ist gar
nicht mehr gerne bei solchen großen
veranstaltungen dabei aber bei pixum ist
sie und ihr könnt ihr wieder fragen
stellen beachtung das faq video und die
wichtigen regeln für die nutzer fragen
das heißt kurz fassen möglichst nur eine
frage und am besten als video frage
hochladen alles andere im effekt juwi
hier und natürlich ganz wichtig die
infos hier unter dem video gucken und
dann wünsche ich viel erfolg kann sind
die chancen groß dass er angeguckt
werdet und nina hagen die frage
beantwortet